hi there steve kaufman here again
uh see if we can get rid of those lights
there there we go
um
yeah my fault my some of my videos were
zapped including my most recent videos
uh i want to i'll start up again here
this is a series called frequently asked
questions
uh on language learning and
i'm steve kaufman as you know of
link.com and
of course i've learned 11 languages so i
have a bit of experience in language
learning
my answers to these frequently asked
questions are based on my own experience
they're not based on any
science
uh i have second language acquisition
one question that is asked is how do you
listen effectively i think many of you
know from listening to my videos that i
very much believe in
a lot of input i think for
certainly at the beginning and for a
long period through your language
learning
experience it's very important to get
the language in you
before you worry about how accurately
you can produce it
and that means listening and reading
and people ask well how do you listen
effectively some people say that they
have trouble concentrating and so forth
well here are some thoughts first of all
the listening experience has to be
enjoyable so get very good earphones all
right and so someone asked what do i use
well i have when i go jogging and the
great thing about listening is you can
do it wherever you are you can do it
washing the dishes while jogging while
uh cross-country skiing and i have this
pair of
sony uh i don't know what they cost i
can't remember
you know they're not the cheapest but
the sound is very good and they hang on
your ears very comfortably so i use them
all the time the sound quality is
excellent
uh
sony you know and get a pair that sort
of hangs on your ear like this
okay so that you don't have to worry
about it falling out
uh
and that's what i normally use however
sometimes my wife plays the piano
or i have a thing called the nordic
track at home which is a little bit
noisy or if i'm sitting in an airplane
then i use these
which are made by a company called
sennheiser and they have a noise guard
thing so you can actually block out
noise but i don't use these very much
because of course my ears will start to
sweat
uh you know when i'm working out so but
for 15-20 minutes on the nordic track
they're fine so invest in quality sound
most of the mp3 players will produce
good sound make sure you have decent uh
earphones other than that here quickly
as i'm running out i want this to be
short basic principles of listening
you're going to tune out don't worry
about it
when you start new in a language at
least i find that i want to listen 20 30
times and then as i progress i listen
less and less frequently to the same
content so if i basically
kind of stop focusing go away from the
listening it doesn't matter listen again
you'll eventually pick up all the
different spots
uh try to
for most of the period until i'm very
good i always want to have a text of
what i'm listening to so that i can then
read it and save words and phrases or
underline phrases focus on the text so
that when i listen again i start to
notice these things i'm not one of those
but there are people who like to do this
i'm not one of those who just likes to
have
the
language sort of
blaring on in the background i like to
actually try to understand what i'm
listening to
and i like to focus on different words
and phrases even if i'm not focusing all
the time
uh listening is is just a big advantage
is you can do it anywhere you want it
enables you to basically
fill in dead time if i had to rely on
other activities i wouldn't study nearly
as much 80 of my language learning
activity is based on listening and if
you listen the way i advise you to you
will find that certain phrases are going
to stay with you phrases that you
listened to two years ago are still
going to be with you
today kind of thing so those are my tips
don't worry if you can't focus all the
time
i find it difficult to focus if i
actually sit down and try to listen but
whereas if i'm doing something else i
find that i am able to focus 60 70 80 of
the time and that really helps the brain
get used to the language so
that's my take on how to listen i hope
that's useful